OK, so let me just ask you this straight off. We're doing a show this week about doomed love.
好的，那我就开门见山地问你。我们这周要做一期关于注定失败的爱情的节目。
Oh.
哦。
What was that "Oh"? What did that "Oh" mean?
刚才那声“哦”是什么意思？那声“哦”代表什么？
Well, I feel like that's the most frequent situation I get. So frequently, they're hopeful and I am really pessimistic.
嗯，我觉得那是找我求助的人中最常见的情况。他们总是满怀希望，而我却非常悲观。
Right.
对。
So we thought to ourselves, me and the people who work on this radio show, OK, Valentine's Day. Let's do a show of incredibly romantic stories. And of course, some of the most romantic stories are stories of doomed love, your Romeo and Juliet kinds of stories. Star-crossed lovers. Somehow the fact that they can never be makes their love seem all the more intense. But when we turned to somebody who you'd think would be seeing lots of these kinds of stories in real life, Amy Dickinson, who writes the "Ask Amy" advice column in about 150 newspapers, she said, yes, she sees stories of doomed love all the time. All the time. It's the most frequent thing that she sees, but usually it is not so romantic.
所以我们——我和这个广播节目的工作人员——心想，好吧，情人节到了，我们要制作一期非常浪漫的故事。当然，最浪漫的一些故事往往是注定失败的爱情，像罗密欧与朱丽叶那样的故事。一对苦命鸳鸯。不知为何，他们无法在一起的事实反而让他们的爱情显得更加炽热。但是，当我们去请教那位在现实生活中应该见过很多这类故事的人——也就是在约150家报纸上撰写“问问艾米”专栏的艾米·迪金森时，她说，是的，她一直在看到注定失败的爱情故事。一直在看。这是她见到的最常见的情况，但通常并不那么浪漫。
OK. Here's one.
好的，这有一个。
"Dear Amy. I'm in love with a very charming older man. He's always there for me when something arises, and I have some doozies arise. We get along well, enjoy each other's company. We hardly ever fight except over the following six things. One, he cheated on me, then when caught, said he stopped. Two, he has female friends he sees and purposely doesn't share those visits with me, and has never introduced me to any of them. Three, I've never met any of his male friends. Four, he's never taken me to work functions, as he has attended several of mine. Five, except for when talking to family, he doesn't acknowledge my presence to callers on the phone. And six, when I catch him lying, hiding something, or disrespecting my feelings, he withdraws, blames me, never apologizes, and says he's in pain over my questioning of his behavior.
“亲爱的艾米，我爱上了一个非常有魅力的大龄男子。每当有事情发生时，他总是在我身边，而我偶尔会遇到一些棘手的问题。我们相处得很好，享受彼此的陪伴。我们几乎从不吵架，除了以下这六件事：第一，他背叛了我，被发现后声称已经停止了。第二，他有一些女性朋友，他私下与她们见面，刻意不告诉我，也从没把我介绍给她们中的任何一个。第三，我从未见过他的任何男性朋友。第四，他从不带我参加他的工作聚会，尽管他参加过好几次我的。第五，除非是和家人通话，否则他在接电话时从不承认我的存在。第六，当我抓到他撒谎、隐瞒事实或不尊重我的感受时，他就会退缩，指责我，从不道歉，并说我对他的行为提出质疑让他感到痛苦。”
At one time, these things hurt me and that hurt turned into insecurity and rage when I wasn't heard and my feelings weren't accepted. Now I think something is fundamentally wrong with this picture. I'm getting mixed signals. What do you think?"
“曾经，这些事情伤害了我，当我的声音被忽视、感受未被接受时，这种伤害就变成了不安全感和愤怒。现在我觉得这幅画面从根本上是有问题的。我收到的信号很矛盾。你觉得呢？”
OK, so he's still seeing other women. He's keeping her a secret. Maybe he's married to somebody else.
好的，所以他还在和别的女人来往。他在瞒着她。也许他已经和别人结婚了。
But that's the only thing that's wrong. Otherwise it's great.
但这只是唯一的问题。除此之外一切都很棒。
So they are totally doomed.
所以他们是彻底没戏了。
Yeah, totally.
是的，彻底没戏。
What are you going to say to her? What did you say to her?
你打算怎么对她说？你当时是怎么说的？
You are, one, totally doomed. Two, absolutely doomed. Three- you know, I'll give her a list.
你会说：第一，你们彻底没戏了。第二，绝对没戏。第三……你知道，我会列个清单给她。
Let me read another one to you. This came in. "Dear Amy. I've been dating a man on and off for at least 15 years. He let me know on the first date that he's a confirmed bachelor. I'm single, too. Sometimes I don't hear from him for more than a year."
我再读一个给你听。这是刚收到的：“亲爱的艾米，我和一个男人分分合合至少15年了。他在第一次约会时就让我知道他是坚定的单身主义者。我也单身。有时他甚至超过一年都不跟我联系。”
Just a second. Doesn't confirmed bachelor mean gay?
等一下。“坚定的单身主义者”难道不是指同性恋吗？
I think so, as we'll see.
我想是的，我们稍后会讲到。
OK.
好吧。
Yeah. "I'm single, too. Sometimes I don't hear from him for more than a year, and then he'll call to go out. Do you think I should always go out with him when he calls? I don't want to seem desperate. Also, do you think I should call him when I don't hear from him? I don't want him to think I'm a chaser. I like him very much and I find him very interesting to talk to. He's also very smart and I like smart men. So far, we've had a very platonic relationship."
是的。“我也单身。有时他一年多都不联系我，然后他又打电话约我出去。你觉得他打电话时我每次都应该答应吗？我不想显得很卑微。另外，你觉得当他不联系我的时候，我应该给他打电话吗？我不想让他觉得我在倒追。我非常喜欢他，觉得和他交谈非常有趣。他也很聪明，我喜欢聪明的男人。到目前为止，我们一直保持着非常柏拉图式的关系。”
He's extremely well-groomed.
他看起来打理得非常整洁。
Right.
对。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah.
是的。
If you put her in the column, are you going to say, "Will and Grace."
如果你把她的来信放进专栏，你会说“威尔和格蕾丝”吗？
Yeah, I do. Oh, yeah. I have done that. I will say, "This man is definitely gay. Just so you know that. That's what's behind the platonic, 15 years, a year between phone calls. He's definitely gay." Yeah, I've done that. "Just FYI."
是的，我会。哦，会的。我确实这么说过。我会说：“这个男人绝对是同性恋。只是让你知道一下。这就是为什么你们保持着这种柏拉图式的关系，长达15年，中间还要隔上一年的通话间隔。他绝对是同性恋。”是的，我确实这么说过。“仅供参考。”
As for the kind of old-fashioned star-crossed love, the romantic kind, where two people are destined for each other and they struggle against great odds and love triumphs-- I should not have asked Amy. She just had a few letters like that. These situations are rare, she says. She had a Jewish woman and a Hindu Sikh man, very much in love, both afraid of how their families were going to react and how they were going to make a life together. She had first cousins, first cousins in love, and though it's legal for them to marry in a dozen states, she says they would face real hurdles with their family. Or there was this letter she got, for her very first column.
至于那种老派的、注定失败的爱情，那种浪漫的，两个注定在一起的人历经磨难而爱情最终获胜的故事……我真不该问艾米的。她几乎没有收到过那样的信。她说，这些情况太罕见了。她曾遇到过一个犹太女人和一个印度锡克教男人，他们非常相爱，但都害怕家人的反应，不知道该如何共同生活。她遇到过表亲相爱的例子，尽管在十二个州他们结婚是合法的，但她说他们会面临来自家庭的真正阻碍。或者还有她收到过的一封信，那是她专栏的第一篇。
This woman was stopping at a gas station every day on her way home from work. And the guy who worked at the gas station had a huge crush on her. And he wrote to me, wondering if he-- even though he's a gas station attendant and she was, he thought, a busy executive, what should he do? And in that case I felt really-- I was young. What did I know? I said, "Go for it. Look for signs that she's interested in you. She seems to be coming to the gas station every single day and buying gas in very small amounts. I think she's interested."
那个女人每天下班回家的路上都会在一个加油站停留。在加油站工作的那个男人非常爱慕她。他写信给我，问他该怎么办——尽管他只是一个加油站员工，而她在他眼里是一位忙碌的高管。在那种情况下，我感到非常……我当时还年轻，我懂什么？我说：“去追求吧。寻找她对你感兴趣的迹象。她似乎每天都来加油，而且每次只加一点点。我认为她对你有意思。”
Right, she's coming there for you.
对，她是为了你才去那儿的。
"If she's finding a reason to talk to you--" because they were chit-chatting.
“如果她能找到理由和你说话的话——”因为他们当时在闲聊。
So, about a week after it ran, I got a letter from her. She said, "I think I'm the woman in the letter. I think I'm the woman who's stopping in. And you know what, I'm interested. What should I do?"
所以，在文章刊登大约一周后，我收到了一封她的回信。她说：“我想我就是信里提到的那个女人。我想我就是每天顺路停车的那个女人。而且你知道吗？我也对他有意思。我该怎么办？”
And I said, "OK. Now I'm out of it. Now I'm getting out of this [UNINTELLIGIBLE]-- Now you take your letter, he'll take his letter, and now you have something real to talk about."
我说：“好了。现在我退出。我不再掺和了——现在你拿着你的信，他拿着他的信，你们现在有真正的共同话题可以聊了。”
So there's a happy story for Valentine's Day.
所以，这算是一个情人节的幸福故事。
Oh. Yeah, well, you could seize on that. A story where you don't know the ending is a happy story.
哦，是啊，你可以抓住这点不放。一个结局未知的爱情故事就是一个幸福的故事。
Listen to the words that you are saying. "Yeah, you can seize on that," meaning that straw, that tiny little straw.
听听你正在说的话。“是的，你可以抓住这点不放”，意思是那根稻草，那根细小的稻草。
Yes, you grab that, baby. You hang on.
是的，抓住它，宝贝。坚持住。
You know what you are? You know what you are? You're like a cop. You know what I mean? All you see is the worst cases.
你知道你是什么吗？你知道你像什么吗？你就像个警察。你明白我的意思吗？你眼里看到的只有最糟糕的案例。
All I see is crooks and scowls. I know.
我眼里看到的只有骗子和苦脸，我知道。
Exactly. All you see is the bad. So you have no idea that it can be something else.
没错。你只看到坏的一面。所以你根本不知道事情还可以有另一种可能。
Yeah. That's right. I've been walking the streets of Hell's Kitchen.
是啊，你说得对。我一直在“地狱厨房”的街头巡逻。
Where is the romance, my friends? Where is the romance these days? Well, today in our program, for Valentine's Day, we head out into the world looking for stories of true love, love that fate is against in every way. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. We bring you three stories of star-crossed love today.
浪漫在哪儿呢，朋友们？如今浪漫还存在吗？嗯，今天我们的节目，为了情人节，我们将走向世界，去寻找真爱的故事，那种在各方面都遭到命运阻挠的爱。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们为您带来三个苦命鸳鸯的故事。
Act One, Prisoner of Love. In that act, two people overcome incredible barriers to their love. Their countries are at war. He's Iraqi. She's American. He is a prisoner. She is his guard.
第一幕，爱的囚徒。在这一幕中，两个人克服了爱情中难以想象的重重阻碍。他们的国家处于战争状态。他是伊拉克人，她是美国人。他是囚犯，她是他的守卫。
Act Two, The Diary of Mrs. Sam Horrigan. A high-school girl tells the story of one doomed love that improbably and accidentally and against her will became a second doomed love story.
第二幕，萨姆·霍里根夫人的日记。一个高中女生讲述了一个注定失败的爱情故事，它出乎意料、阴差阳错地违背她的意愿，演变成了第二个注定失败的爱情故事。
Act Three, So a Chipmunk and a Squirrel Walk Into a Bar. In that act, a brand-new story by David Sedaris, a look inside what it is really like, really truly like, when families disapprove, when society looks down its nose, where there's a love and one of you is a chipmunk and the other is a squirrel. Stay with us.
第三幕，花栗鼠和松鼠走进一家酒吧。在这一幕中，戴维·塞达里斯带来了一个全新的故事，揭示了当家人反对、社会瞧不起你时，那种真实的、确确实实的感受，特别是当爱情的一方是花栗鼠，而另一方是松鼠时。请继续收听。
Act One, Prisoner of Love. This is a kind of unlikely love story, and the only reason that it could happen at all is a series of very unlikely events that precede it. And, I've got to say, we're going to dwell on those events here for a minute or two, because they really are kind of incredible.
第一幕，爱的囚徒。这是一个有点不可思议的爱情故事，它之所以能发生，完全是因为之前发生了一系列极不可能的事件。而且，我必须说，我们要在这里花上一两分钟回顾一下这些事件，因为它们真的有些不可思议。
It starts with a kid, this kid, Shant Kenderian, who's Armenian, born and raised in Baghdad. When he's 13, his parents divorce. He goes to live with his mom in suburban Illinois, outside Chicago. Basically, he becomes an American kid, fluent in English. The summer before his senior year, he goes to visit his dad in Iraq. He's there for a few days. The Iran-Iraq war starts. Borders are closed. He's stuck.
故事始于一个孩子，这个叫尚特·肯德里安的孩子，他是亚美尼亚人，在巴格达出生长大。13岁时，父母离婚了。他随母亲搬到了芝加哥郊外的伊利诺伊州生活。基本上，他成了一个精通英语的美国孩子。高三那年的夏天，他回伊拉克探望父亲。在那里待了几天，两伊战争爆发了。边界关闭，他被困住了。
Soon enough, he's drafted into the Iran-Iraq war. He spends three and a half years fighting the Iranians. He's at the front lines. He's near Basra. The war ends. After the war, borders are reopened. He begins applying again to renew his US green card and join his mother, who's now moved to LA. Then, before that process is completed, Iraq invades Kuwait. Again, borders close. All the men under 55 are drafted. Shant ends up in the Iraqi navy. Who even knew they had a navy, right?
没过多久，他就被征召参加两伊战争。他在前线与伊朗人作战了三年半，就在巴士拉附近。战争结束后，边界重新开放。他再次申请更新美国绿卡，想要回到已经搬到洛杉矶的母亲身边。然后，在该流程完成之前，伊拉克入侵了科威特。边界再次关闭。所有55岁以下的男子都被征召入伍。尚特最终进入了伊拉克海军。谁会想到他们还有海军，对吧？
So in a tiny boat-- it's like a landing craft. Only two of the 30 guys on the boat actually have guns. Very little food, very little water. Their job is-- here's their mission. Are you ready? They're supposed to sail into the Persian Gulf, tossing 400-pound floating mines into the water. Now, normally, these kinds of mines, you anchor them down to the bottom, and you keep track of where they are on a map, so you know where they are. Their mission? They're just supposed to toss them off the side of the boat and then gun the engine to get away before the mines float back up and explode. So then they drop the mines. And what they're supposed to do is drop the mines, pass through these waters, and then drive back through the same water that they've just littered with mines. That's their job. OK.
所以，他坐在一艘小船上——那就像是一艘登陆艇。船上的30个人里只有两个人有枪。食物极少，水极少。他们的任务是——你准备好了吗？他们要驶入波斯湾，往水里扔400磅重的浮动水雷。通常，这种水雷是锚定在海底的，你在地图上记录它们的位置，所以你知道它们在哪儿。他们的任务呢？他们只是从船边把它们扔下去，然后猛踩油门逃跑，赶在水雷浮上来爆炸之前离开。所以他们扔下水雷，穿过这片海域，然后又得开回他们刚刚布满水雷的海域。这就是他们的工作。好吧。
So, for Shant and the other guys in the boat, the way that they saw it is that their greatest hope of getting out of all this alive is that they would be captured, captured and captured quickly by the Americans. And in fact, after boat fires and air attacks, the Americans see them. They attack. They abandon ship. They're floating in this little life raft, waiting to be taken prisoner, not sure what's going to happen to them next. All right. Here's Shant. He's going to read from a memoir that he wrote.
所以，对尚特和船上的其他人来说，他们认为能活着逃出去的最大希望就是被捕，而且是尽快被美国人俘虏。事实上，在船只起火和空袭之后，美国人发现了他们。美军发动攻击，他们弃船逃生。他们漂浮在那个小救生筏上，等待被俘，不知道接下来会发生什么。好了，这是尚特。他将朗读他撰写的回忆录片段。
While the helicopter orbited around the life raft and boat, it passed by the raft once every few minutes. Ahmed was excited, like a little puppy. He followed the helicopter with his eyes and whole body, making it very uncomfortable in the crowded raft. When the helicopter made a sudden turn, Ahmed too swung around, and elbowed Riyadh in his already-injured face, giving him a nosebleed. Whenever the helicopter came close to the raft, we cheered and waved at the pilot in an overly friendly gesture. After doing this a dozen times, I explained to my Iraqi friends that the pilot understood the message. We didn't need to cheer anymore. Two more helicopters came, followed by a large missile frigate.
直升机在救生筏和小船上空盘旋，每隔几分钟就会经过筏子一次。艾哈迈德很兴奋，像只小狗一样。他用眼睛和整个身体追随着直升机，让拥挤的筏子上的人感到非常不舒服。当直升机突然转弯时，艾哈迈德也跟着转，肘部撞到了利亚德那张已经受伤的脸上，导致他鼻血直流。每当直升机靠近筏子，我们就欢呼并以一种过于友好的姿态向飞行员挥手。在做了十几次之后，我向我的伊拉克朋友们解释，飞行员已经明白我们的意图了。我们不需要再欢呼了。又来了两架直升机，后面跟着一艘大型导弹护卫舰。
"They're going to kill us," cried Ahmed.
“他们要杀了我们，”艾哈迈德哭喊道。
"Don't be ridiculous. We surrendered," I told him. "They're here to pick us up."
“别傻了。我们已经投降了，”我告诉他。“他们是来接我们的。”
"Do you think they will beat us up or torture us?" Munther asked this time.
“你觉得他们会殴打我们或者折磨我们吗？”蒙瑟这次问道。
"I don't think so," I said.
“我不这么认为，”我说。
"But weren't they the ones who dropped nuclear bombs on Japan? And what about the war they fought in Vietnam? I read that many Americans married Vietnamese women, and when the war was over, they left them behind with their children." Apparently, Munther had been reading some Iraqi propaganda.
“但难道不是他们向日本投掷了核弹吗？还有他们在越南打的那场战争呢？我读到过很多美国男人娶了越南女人，战争结束后，他们就把她们和孩子留在了那里。”显然，蒙瑟读过一些伊拉克的宣传材料。
"They didn't do this to torture the Vietnamese women," I said. "I really don't think anyone's going to marry you and leave you behind." A wave of laughter shook the raft.
“他们这样做并不是为了折磨那些越南女人，”我说。“我真的不认为有人会娶了你然后再把你抛下。”筏子上传来一阵笑声。
There were approximately 100 Americans out on the deck of the missile frigate. We saw smiling faces, cameras flashing, and video cameras. For each Iraqi on the life raft, there were at least two or three guns and one camera pointed at us, ready to go off. The contrast between the American and Iraqi soldiers was astounding. They looked like athletes, like swimmers and boxers and football players. We stood with our wasted bodies, malnourished and plagued. We felt like an inferior species.
导弹护卫舰的甲板上大约有100名美国人。我们看到了微笑的面孔，闪烁的照相机和摄像机。救生筏上的每个伊拉克人，至少有两到三支枪和一部摄像机对准我们，随时准备按下快门。美国士兵和伊拉克士兵之间的对比是惊人的。他们看起来像运动员，像游泳运动员、拳击手和足球运动员。而我们站在那里，身体消瘦，营养不良，疾病缠身。我们觉得自己仿佛是一个劣等物种。
We had, between 15 of us, two guns, one helmet, and 15 old gas masks. Each American soldier had his own gun, helmet, gas mask, bulletproof vest, eye protection goggles, flashlights, and ear plugs. Ear plugs. The luxury of that amazed me. Here was a country that respected its soldiers so much it would even take care of their ears. I must have stared too long, because the guard became uncomfortable and told me to look away.
我们15个人里只有两支枪、一个头盔和15个旧防毒面具。而每个美国士兵都有自己的枪、头盔、防毒面具、防弹衣、护目镜、手电筒和耳塞。耳塞。那种奢侈程度让我感到震惊。这是一个如此尊重士兵的国家，甚至会照顾到他们的耳朵。我一定盯着看太久了，因为守卫感到不舒服，让我看向别处。
I was the 11th prisoner aboard the USS Curts, and the 23rd POW of Desert Storm. It was noon of January 24, 1991, eight days into the war.
我是“柯茨”号导弹护卫舰上的第11名囚犯，也是“沙漠风暴”行动的第23名战俘。那是1991年1月24日中午，战争爆发后的第八天。
So the Americans figure out right away that Shant is different from all these other prisoners. For one thing, he's fluent in English. Because of that, they assume that either he is a high-ranking Iraqi officer or he's a spy. He is put through many, many interrogations with a revolving cast of American interrogators. He writes that actually his treatment is not so bad, but it is harrowing. He is constantly blindfolded and handcuffed and forced to spend several days with real Iraqi officers in an outdoor pit dug in the sand at a base in Saudi Arabia.
所以美国人很快就发现尚特与其他囚犯不同。首先，他英语流利。正因为如此，他们要么认定他是伊拉克高级军官，要么认定他是间谍。他经历了无数次审讯，面对轮番上阵的美国审讯官。他写道，实际上他的待遇不算太差，但确实非常折磨人。他总是被蒙着眼睛、戴着手铐，被迫与真正的伊拉克军官一起在沙特阿拉伯基地沙地上挖的一个露天坑里待了好几天。
After about six weeks of this, he says, he's sent to another POW camp, the 403rd, where he's supposed to wait to be transferred to Saudi custody. He of course does not want Saudi custody. He wants to go to America. And it's at the 403rd that the Americans start to believe his story. And they can use his translation skills, so they make him a trustee, meaning that he acts as kind of an employee, and has more freedom and he isn't subject to interrogations anymore. And it's while working at the 403rd that he meets Monica.
他说，在大约六周后，他被送往另一个战俘营，即403号战俘营，等待移交给沙特方面羁押。他当然不想被沙特羁押。他想去美国。也就是在403号营地，美国人开始相信他的故事了。而且他们可以利用他的翻译技能，所以他们让他担任了管理员，这意味着他表现得像个雇员，有了更多的自由，也不再受审讯了。正是在403号营地工作期间，他遇到了莫妮卡。
It was perhaps the second day at the 403rd when the Americans asked if I could help unload some boxes of MREs. The truck driver happened to be an attractive young female soldier. She handed down the boxes from the truck bed while we stacked them in the supply tent nearby. The two Iraqi POWs who were helping me found it highly strange to interact with a woman in this way.
那大概是在403号营地的第二天，美国人问我能不能帮忙卸一些MRE（即开即食口粮）箱子。卡车司机碰巧是一位迷人的年轻女兵。她从卡车车厢上把箱子递下来，我们把它们堆在附近的一个补给帐篷里。帮忙的两个伊拉克战俘觉得以这种方式与女性互动非常奇怪。
"Do they do the same work as men?" asked one of them.
“她们做的工作和男人一样吗？”其中一个人问道。
"It looks like it. See? This one is driving a truck," answered the other. Women drove cars in Iraq, but it was unheard of to see one driving a truck.
“看起来是。你看？这个人在开卡车，”另一个人回答。在伊拉克，女性会开车，但看到女性开卡车是闻所未闻的。
"American guys don't seem to care if there are females among them," said the first.
“美国男人似乎并不介意队伍里有女性，”第一个人说。
The second one smiled. "I'm sure it's a different story at night."
第二个人笑了笑。“我敢肯定到了晚上情况就不同了。”
The guys seemed baffled at how the male American soldiers interacted with the woman in such a matter-of-fact way. As for me, I had lived in the US. In Iraq, we were Christians, not Muslims, so I had enjoyed plenty of social interaction with women. I wasn't inclined to fall in love just because a female soldier handed me a box of MREs. Still, I was hardly desensitized to her presence either. She was beautiful. She had red hair. She smiled.
他们似乎对美国男兵以如此平常的方式与女性互动感到困惑。至于我，我曾在美居住。在伊拉克，我们是基督徒，不是穆斯林，所以我享受过很多与女性的社交互动。我并没有仅仅因为一个女兵递给我一盒口粮就爱上她的倾向。不过，我也很难对她的存在无动于衷。她很美。她有一头红发。她微笑着。
While we were working to unload the truck, I was aware that she had noticed me too, but more in a way where she actually seemed to be looking away from me a little more than one normally would in a work-together situation. I continued unloading the truck, reminding myself that I wasn't there to find a girlfriend in a POW camp. When we'd finally finished unloading the MREs, she came over to talk. We introduced ourselves. Monica was her name. It turned out she had heard about me, and was curious to learn about my journey from high school in the Chicago suburbs to prisoner of war in Saudi Arabia.
在我们卸货时，我意识到她也注意到了我，但更多时候，她似乎在刻意回避与我的对视，这在合作的工作场景中并不常见。我继续卸着卡车，提醒自己来战俘营不是为了找女朋友。当我们终于卸完口粮，她走过来聊天。我们做了自我介绍。她叫莫妮卡。原来她听说过我，很好奇想了解我的经历，从芝加哥郊区的高中到沙特阿拉伯的战俘营。
I told her about myself. I couldn't tell what she was thinking, but she listened intently, and only interrupted to ask more questions. I was surprised by how good it felt to have this woman show a genuine interest in me as an individual human being and not just some enemy soldier. It wasn't really anything specific she said. She asked me the same questions I was asked every day during interrogation. The difference was in her body language, the way she leaned on her truck beside me, and the sound of her voice.
我告诉了她关于我的一切。我看不出她在想什么，但她听得很认真，只有在问更多问题时才会打断我。让我惊讶的是，这个女人以一个独立个体的身份而不是仅仅作为敌军战俘对我表现出真正的兴趣，这种感觉竟如此美好。并不是她说的具体内容，而是她问我的问题和我每天审讯中被问的问题一样。不同之处在于她的肢体语言，她靠在卡车边挨着我的方式，还有她说话的声音。
Over the next few days, I watched Monica a lot. She had this breezy, warm, gentle air about her that seemed so California to me. It was just her smile and laugh, the way she brought a playful atmosphere into the processing tent, something I never would have expected in the military during wartime. She totally contrasted with this harsh and deadly place.
接下来的几天里，我经常观察莫妮卡。她身上有一种轻盈、温暖、温柔的气息，让我觉得很有加州风情。这仅仅是她的笑容和笑声，以及她带给处理帐篷的那种轻松氛围，这是我在战时军事环境中从未预料到的。她与这个残酷且充满杀戮的地方形成了鲜明对比。
For the next several days, the words "good morning" and "good night" were all that we said to one another. In the beginning, I was careful never to greet her first, since I had this little problem of being an enemy POW. And when I returned her greeting, I was careful to use the American custom of meeting a woman's gaze directly but not staring at her. Things began to change when Wik, an American soldier who I translated for, brought me up as a topic of conversation with Monica.
随后的几天里，“早安”和“晚安”是我们之间说的全部内容。一开始，我很小心，从不先跟她打招呼，因为我有身为敌方战俘的困扰。而当我回应她的问候时，我很小心地运用美国习惯，直视女性的目光但不过度凝视。当威克——我为他担任翻译的一名美国士兵——把我和莫妮卡当作谈资时，情况开始发生变化。
"Do you know him already?" he asked Monica, gesturing with his head at me.
“你已经认识他了吗？”他问莫妮卡，头朝我这边示意。
"Yes, he's my friend," she answered simply. Then she offered her hand to shake mine. "You are my friend, aren't you?" I was just so self-conscious about the odd situation.
“是的，他是我的朋友，”她简单地回答。然后她伸出手想和我握手。“你是我的朋友，对吧？”我对自己这种奇怪的处境感到非常局促不安。
Then when Wik learned that Monica and her truck were free, he asked Lieutenant Cunningham's permission for all three of us to go to the 401st, where I was previously held, and retrieve my money and other belongings which were still there. With permission granted, Wik grabbed his M-16 and sat with me in the truck bed while Monica drove a winding and bumpy dirt road.
后来，当威克得知莫妮卡和她的卡车有空时，他请求坎宁安中尉批准我们三人去401号营地——我之前关押的地方，取回我仍在那里存放的钱和其他财物。获得批准后，威克抓起他的M-16步枪和我坐在卡车后厢，莫妮卡开着车走在蜿蜒颠簸的泥路上。
When we got to the 401st, I wanted to go with Wik, but he suggested that it might be better if I stayed in the truck. I was nervous about being left alone with Monica, especially when she stepped out and sat next to me on the truck bed. But then she began talking, openly and with no apparent awkwardness. It felt intoxicating. Here I was, alone with this lovely woman in this improbable place. Normally, this would have been a perfect opportunity to ask her out, which I know seems ridiculous. It was only Monica's matter-of-fact friendliness that kept the closeness from being overwhelming. It was there that I first began to realize that I was carrying feelings for this woman, for this soldier.
当我们到达401号营地时，我想和威克一起去，但他建议我最好待在车里。我和莫妮卡单独待在一起感到很紧张，特别是当她走下车坐在卡车后厢挨着我时。但随后她开始说话，语气开放且毫无明显的尴尬。那种感觉令人沉醉。我竟然和这个可爱的女人单独待在这个不可思议的地方。通常，这本该是约她出去的绝佳机会，我知道这看起来很荒谬。正是莫妮卡那种实事求是的友好，让那种亲密感没有变得令人难以承受。就是在那里，我第一次意识到我开始对这个女人、这个士兵产生了感情。
Monica's work as a truck driver kept her away from the compound most of the time. When she came, she would only be in the processing tent for a short time, but she always made sure to say hello. Sometimes, she would ask for more details about all that happened to me, the treatment I received at the Marines camp and joint interrogation facility. To me, the treatment didn't seem as atrocious as she felt it was. After all, I had been hoping to get captured by the Americans. It seemed the only alternative to certain death. My extended stay in the interrogation camp didn't bother me, so long as I remained in American custody.
莫妮卡担任卡车司机的工作让她大部分时间都远离营地。当她来的时候，她只会在处理帐篷里待很短的时间，但她总是确保打个招呼。有时，她会询问我所有事情的细节，我在海军陆战队营地和联合审讯设施受到的待遇。对我来说，这种待遇并不像她认为的那样惨无人道。毕竟，我一直希望能被美国人俘虏。这似乎是面对必死之境的唯一选择。我在审讯营的长期逗留并没有困扰我，只要我仍然在美国人的监管下。
I also told her about my flashbacks and nightmares. In my dreams, I would often see myself trapped again in Iraq, or that Saddam likes me and wants me to always be near him. So I had to pretend that I liked him too, or else face death.
我还告诉了她我的闪回和噩梦。在梦里，我经常看到自己再次被困在伊拉克，或者萨达姆喜欢我，想让我永远待在他身边。所以我必须假装我也喜欢他，否则就会面临死亡。
While Monica listened to my stories, at one point I felt her hand gently rub my back. I was afraid to comment on it, so I just kept on going. "I don't know if I will ever be able to forget these things," I said.
当莫妮卡听我的故事时，有一次我感觉到她的手轻轻抚摸着我的背。我不敢评论，所以我就继续说了下去。“我不知道我是否能忘记这些事情，”我说。
"You probably never will forget them, but eventually they won't be so painful anymore." She paused for a moment, then changed the subject. "Do you have a girlfriend in Iraq?"
“你可能永远无法忘记它们，但最终它们不会再那么痛苦了。”她停顿了片刻，然后转换了话题。“你在伊拉克有女朋友吗？”
I was afraid to even hope that this might mean that she felt some special interest in me, so I give her an answer that stuck to the facts. The Iraqi society is more westernized than many Arab countries, but still most marriages are arranged. Couples have to date in secret with the intent to marry. I was attracted to a few girls, but I never made any advances.
我甚至不敢奢望这可能意味着她对我有什么特殊兴趣，所以我给了她一个客观的回答。伊拉克社会比许多阿拉伯国家更西化，但大多数婚姻仍然是包办的。情侣必须秘密约会，并以结婚为前提。我被几个女孩吸引过，但我从未有过任何追求。
"Why not?" she asked.
“为什么不呢？”她问。
"I don't want to have a family. I never expected to survive the Iran-Iraq war, and if I did, I didn't want any ties to hinder my attempts in escaping Iraq and returning to America."
“我不想要家庭。我从未指望能从两伊战争中幸存下来，如果我幸存下来，我也不想有任何牵绊阻碍我逃离伊拉克并回到美国。”
"Do you like children?" she asked.
“你喜欢孩子吗？”她问。
"To tell you the truth, I usually don't give them any special attention, but they seem to like to play with me anyway. The same thing is true with dogs."
“老实说，我通常不会特别关注他们，但他们似乎还是喜欢和我玩。对狗也一样。”
Monica smiled. "Children and dogs know a nice person when they see one."
莫妮卡笑了。“孩子和狗能看出谁是个好人。”
On the surface, we appeared to have little in common. Monica was a waitress from the Midwest, a people person who joined the Army Reserve to help make ends meet. Her life was tough in many ways, with family crises and financial difficulty, yet simple in so many others, such as one would expect from a small-town life in a free country.
表面上看，我们几乎没有共同点。莫妮卡是来自中西部的一名女服务员，是一个乐于助人的人，为了维持生计加入了陆军预备役。她的生活在许多方面都很艰难，有着家庭危机和经济困难，但在许多其他方面却很简单，就像在自由国家的小镇生活中所期待的那样。
The stakes were very high, though. If we allowed our friendship to go any deeper and we were caught, Monica could be reprimanded. There was no telling how seriously. I could have easily been stripped from my special trustee status and transferred to the general population of Iraqi POWs. My interaction with the Americans would then diminish, and with it, all my hopes of returning to the United States would vanish.
然而，赌注非常高。如果我们允许我们的友谊深入发展而被发现，莫妮卡可能会受到训斥。很难说会有多严重。我很容易就会被剥夺特殊管理员身份，被转移到一般的伊拉克战俘群体中。我与美国人的互动就会减少，随之而来的，我重返美国的希望也将烟消云散。
But the more we tried to stay away from each other, the more our feelings grew. Up to now, I had always thought that love should start from the head and only later be allowed into the heart. I thought that logic had to prevail over irrational emotional impulses, or forces that might attract us into relationships too difficult to maintain. Romeo and Juliet, for example, should have known never to fall in love. But my theories were of little help when it came to Monica.
但我们越是试图远离对方，我们的感情就越深。一直以来，我总认为爱应该始于头脑，后来才允许进入心灵。我认为逻辑必须战胜非理性的情感冲动，或者那些可能将我们吸引进难以维持的关系中的力量。例如，罗密欧与朱丽叶本该知道永远不要坠入爱河。但当我面对莫妮卡时，我的这些理论几乎毫无用处。
Although no one else had made any comments yet about our association together, I was sure that back at their camp, the guys had plenty to say. It was clear that people were noticing the attraction between us. Soon, I decided that I needed to use my head and limit this budding relationship with Monica. After all, she was one of my American captors. So I convinced myself that whatever time I spent with her should be no different than with the other female soldiers around the admin compound.
虽然还没有其他人对我们的交往发表过任何评论，但我敢肯定在他们的营地里，那些家伙肯定议论纷纷。很明显，人们注意到了我们之间的吸引力。很快，我决定我需要用头脑行事，限制这段与莫妮卡的萌芽中的关系。毕竟，她是我的美国俘虏者之一。所以我说服自己，无论我花多少时间和她在一起，都不应该与其他行政大院里的女兵有什么不同。
On the following day, Monica was mostly running errands somewhere outside the admin compound. During the few times that she was briefly present, I made it a point to walk away from the processing tent and not to return until her truck was gone.
第二天，莫妮卡大多时间在行政大院外跑腿。在她短暂出现的几次里，我刻意离开处理帐篷，直到她的卡车离开才回来。
Later in the afternoon I was sitting on a bench inside the processing tent, drawing on a sketchpad while waiting for another translation assignment. I was so intent on my drawing that I didn't notice that she had entered the processing tent until she sat next to me and simply asked, "What are you doing?"
下午晚些时候，我坐在处理帐篷里的长椅上，在画纸上素描，等待下一个翻译任务。我太专注于画画了，以至于没有注意到她进了处理帐篷，直到她坐在我身边简单地问：“你在做什么？”
"I'm trying to draw," I said. I didn't lift my eyes from the paper. Monica stood up and walked away.
“我在尝试画画，”我说。我没有把目光从纸上移开。莫妮卡站起来走开了。
For the rest of the day, she didn't come near me or even look my way. From that moment on, I didn't have to avoid her or pretend to go to the bathroom every time she entered the compound. She had taken the hint and was staying away from me. So much for what my head wanted.
那天剩下的时间里，她没有靠近我，甚至没有往我这边看一眼。从那一刻起，我不必再躲着她，也不必在她进入大院时假装去上厕所了。她已经领会了我的暗示，离我远远的。我的头脑想要的也就到此为止了。
But Monica was not the type who would leave things unsettled. Before she went home for the night, she asked me to sit with her in the truck. "Why were you avoiding me all day?" she asked.
但莫妮卡不是那种会让事情悬而未决的人。在她回家过夜之前，她让我坐在她的卡车里。“你为什么整天都在躲着我？”她问。
The directness of her question stabbed at me. All I could say was, "Monica, you've been very kind to me. I just don't want to cause you any trouble. Your commanders could get all sorts of terrible ideas about this. They might think I'm trying to use you. I think, Monica, I think we should stop being friends."
她问题的直接性刺痛了我。我只能说：“莫妮卡，你对我一直很好。我只是不想给你惹任何麻烦。你的指挥官可能会对此产生各种可怕的想法。他们可能认为我试图利用你。我想，莫妮卡，我想我们应该停止做朋友了。”
She was quiet for a moment. "Listen, Shant. I know how to keep myself out of trouble. It's true that the guys have been talking about our friendship, but I also heard Sergeant Shepherd tell them that it was nobody's business what I do." She waited for me to respond. I was lost for words. I could barely look at her. My throat tightened. "The guys can talk all they want," she continued. "But I want to be your friend, Shant. I love you."
她安静了一会儿。“听着，尚特。我知道如何保护自己不受麻烦。没错，大家一直在谈论我们的友谊，但我也听到谢泼德中士告诉他们，我做什么关他们屁事。”她等着我回应。我哑口无言。我几乎不敢看她。喉咙发紧。“大家想说什么就说什么吧，”她继续说道。“但我想要做你的朋友，尚特。我爱你。”
I held her hand and said, "I love you too, Monica." She kissed my hand and I kissed hers. And that simple gesture of affection was one of the most powerful emotional experiences that I had ever had.
我握着她的手说：“我也爱你，莫妮卡。”她亲吻了我的手，我也亲吻了她的。那种简单的亲昵动作是我经历过的最强大的情感体验之一。
She smiled and said, "You didn't expect to go to war and find yourself a girl, did you?"
她微笑着说：“你没料到会去打仗还能找个女朋友吧？”
"This is crazy," I said, and I don't doubt that she felt the same way.
“这太疯狂了，”我说，我不怀疑她也有同样的感觉。
"It's funny how everyone preaches that we should love our enemy," she replied. Then she changed the subject. We talked for nearly an hour. I kept telling myself to leave, without success.
“人们总是宣扬我们应该爱我们的敌人，这很有趣，”她回答。然后她转换了话题。我们聊了将近一个小时。我不断告诉自己要离开，但没能成功。
A few days later, Monica asked me to help her carry some containers of liquid detergent into the supply tent. Once we were alone, she opened her arms and gave me a very long hug. I let my guard down and forgot that I was a POW for a moment. We didn't kiss. We just hugged. But the next day, she asked me into the supply tent again. She kissed me on the cheek, and I kissed her back.
几天后，莫妮卡让我帮她把几桶液体洗涤剂搬进补给帐篷。一旦我们单独在一起，她敞开双臂给了我一个很长的拥抱。我放下防备，在那一刻忘记了自己是个战俘。我们没有接吻。我们只是拥抱。但第二天，她再次叫我进补给帐篷。她亲吻了我的脸颊，我也亲吻了她作为回应。
It was not a passionate kiss. It couldn't have been. The processing tent, with everybody in it, was less than 15 feet away. Anyone could have walked in on us at any time. We decided that the risk was too great. Before anyone could notice that we were gone too long, we stepped back out.
那不是一个热烈的吻。也不可能是。处理帐篷里所有人都在，距离不到15英尺。任何人随时都可能走进来撞见我们。我们决定风险太大。在有人注意到我们消失太久之前，我们走了出来。
"I wish that we were together," Monica said, "in civilian clothing, holding hands and walking down the streets of my hometown. People would see us but no one would care at all." Monica was wistful. She seemed a million miles away.
“我真希望我们能在一起，”莫妮卡说，“穿着平民服装，手牵着手走在我家乡的街道上。人们会看到我们，但没人会在意。”莫妮卡怅然若失。她似乎远在天边。
After I spent a month with the 403rd, the US army was beginning the transfer of POWs to Saudi camps. They were preparing to go back to America without me. At least, with fewer POWs in the camp, the workload was relaxed, and I found myself spending more time with Monica. By now, our friendship was widely known, but no one seemed to mind. We sat on the bench and played cards in the processing tent. I won, she cheated, I stopped her from cheating, and she called out to a nearby officer, "Sir. He cheats, sir."
我在403号营地待了一个月后，美军开始将战俘转移到沙特营地。他们准备把我一个人留在后面回美国。至少，随着营地里战俘减少，工作量减轻了，我发现自己有更多时间和莫妮卡在一起。此时，我们的友谊已广为人知，但似乎没人介意。我们坐在长椅上在处理帐篷里打牌。我赢了，她作弊，我阻止她作弊，她对着附近的军官喊道：“长官。他作弊，长官。”
The officer shook his head and muttered, "Just like my kids. Just like my kids."
军官摇摇头咕哝道：“就像我的孩子们一样。就像我的孩子们一样。”
Monica giggled and whispered in my ear, "He says everything twice."
莫妮卡咯咯地笑，在我耳边轻声说：“他把每句话都说两遍。”
"That's very unusual. That's very unusual," I replied.
“那太不寻常了。那太不寻常了，”我回答。
Enclosure One closed down, and I was transferred to Enclosure Two, which was scheduled to close down 10 days later. On my second day there, Monica stopped visiting. When I saw her truck, a man was driving it. My heart was crushed. Monica's truck had been taken away, and she had no way to come and visit me again. Without her, my days were longer, and my POW wristband was heavier. I stood at the barbed wire boundaries of the admin compound. I stood watching for a long time, until I finally recognized Monica. She was too far away to notice me or hear my voice if I screamed. Although she had somehow lost possession of her truck, I was still hoping to be with her one more time. I stood like an animal in a cage, longing for his master.
一号围场关闭了，我被转移到二号围场，预计10天后关闭。在那里待的第二天，莫妮卡停止了探访。当我看到她的卡车时，是一个男人在开车。我的心碎了。莫妮卡的卡车被收走了，她再也没有办法来探望我了。没有她，我的日子变得漫长，我的战俘腕带也变得沉重。我站在行政大院的铁丝网边界。我站着看了很久，直到终于认出了莫妮卡。她离得太远了，如果我大喊，她也无法注意到我或听到我的声音。尽管她不知何故失去了卡车，但我仍然希望再和她在一起一次。我像笼子里的野兽一样站着，渴望着主人。
I waited for her every day behind the barbed wire, until I gave up hope that I would ever see her again. I had four more days before my transfer, 100 miles north, deep into the Saudi desert. I was particularly anxious to see Monica, because she'd asked for my mother's phone number in Los Angeles and volunteered to call her for me. After three days of waiting miserably, I was sitting beside one of the lieutenants in the kitchen tent when Monica suddenly appeared and blurted, "I want to talk to Shant, sir. I called his mom in the United States, and I need to talk to him." The lieutenant gave us permission to go and talk.
我每天都在铁丝网后等着她，直到我放弃了还会再见到她的希望。在我转移到100英里以北、沙特沙漠深处之前，我还有四天时间。我特别想见到莫妮卡，因为她向我要了我母亲在洛杉矶的电话号码，并自愿帮我给她打电话。在痛苦地等待了三天后，我正坐在厨房帐篷里的一名中尉旁边，莫妮卡突然出现并脱口而出：“我想和尚特谈谈，长官。我给他在美国的妈妈打了电话，我需要和他谈谈。”中尉给了我们去谈话的许可。
Monica looked like she'd been crying for hours. She told me they took her truck to stop her from visiting me. "I feel helpless," she said. "I can't protect you anymore. They're going to transfer you to the Saudis in three days." She stopped talking and bowed her head, hiding her face from me.
莫妮卡看起来像是已经哭了几个小时。她告诉我，他们收走了她的卡车以阻止她探望我。“我感到很无助，”她说。“我无法再保护你了。三天后他们要把你移交给沙特人。”她停止说话，低下头，把脸藏起来不让我看。
I felt horrible, but all I wanted to do was reassure her. "Don't worry about me, Monica. I'll be fine." I took out three letters, handed them over to her, and said, "Here. I wrote you a letter for each day you didn't come."
我感到很难过，但我只想安慰她。“别担心我，莫妮卡。我会没事的。”我拿出三封信递给她，说：“给你。你没来的每一天，我都为你写了一封信。”
She put the letters in her pocket, wiped her tears away, and started to tell me about my mother. She had given my mother the number to fax my proof of [? permanent ?] residency and other supporting documents I would need to be released. Monica and I talked for a long time. Seeing how upset she was, I tried not to talk about my imminent transfer to the Saudis and concentrate on the glimmer of hope that my documents would arrive and somehow save me. Monica looked up at me. "Whenever you make it to the States, make sure you call me." And with that, we both said our goodbyes for the night. I wonder now if we both knew we were lying a little.
她把信放进兜里，擦掉眼泪，开始跟我谈论我的母亲。她已经给了我母亲传真号码，以便传真我释放所需永久居留权的证明和其他支持文件。莫妮卡和我谈了很久。看到她如此难过，我尽量不谈即将到来的沙特转移，而是专注于文件会寄到并以某种方式拯救我的那一丝希望。莫妮卡抬头看着我。“无论你什么时候到了美国，一定要给我打电话。”就这样，我们在夜晚告别。我怀疑我们当时是否都知道我们都撒了一点谎。
Thanks to her help, and the help of a few other soldiers, I made it from Saudi Arabia to the United States just two weeks later. Monica came back from the Army two or three months after that. When I called her, she was cold. Then she said she was engaged. The guys from her unit told me later that after I left, she cried all the time. Then she met someone else.
多亏了她的帮助，以及其他几名士兵的帮助，两周后我从沙特阿拉伯成功抵达美国。莫妮卡在那之后两三个月从军队回来。当我给她打电话时，她态度冷淡。然后她说她订婚了。她所在部队的人后来告诉我，我离开后，她一直都在哭。然后她遇到了别人。
In a way, we were doomed from the start. But all the hardest things in a relationship-- the fact that I was Iraqi and she was an American, the fact that our countries were at war and I was her enemy, that I was a prisoner and she was one of my guards-- we were able to overcome. What ended up dooming it in the end was the most ordinary thing of all. She couldn't wait for me.
从某种意义上说，我们从一开始就注定失败。但爱情中最艰难的事情——我是伊拉克人她是美国人，我们的国家在交战而我是她的敌人，我是囚犯而她是我的守卫之一——我们都克服了。最终导致结局注定失败的却是最普通的事情。她没能等我。
We didn't have control over the war or the politics of our countries. We didn't have control over where we were born, where we came from or were going to. But the one thing that we had control over, being able to wait for each other, being patient, that's the thing that broke us up. She didn't love me enough for that.
我们无法控制战争或我们国家的政治。我们无法控制出生在哪里、从哪里来或去哪里。但我们唯一能控制的事情——能够等待对方，保持耐心，这才是导致我们分手的原因。她对我的爱不足以支撑这一点。
Shant Kenderian, reading an excerpt from his book, 1001 Nights in Iraq: The Shocking Story of an American Forced to Fight for Saddam Against the Country That He Loves. The book will be out in June from Atria Books.
尚特·肯德里安，朗读他的书《伊拉克的一千零一夜：一个被强迫为萨达姆对抗他所爱国家的美国人的震撼故事》的片段。该书将于六月由阿特里亚出版社出版。
Shant is happily married. When he tried to describe his wife in an email, he said that she is truly a gift from God. They have two daughters.
尚特现在婚姻幸福。当他在邮件中试图描述他的妻子时，他说她是上帝赐予的真正礼物。他们有两个女儿。
Coming up, what if fate makes it so that you and your love don't have much to talk about? Are you doomed? Is that enough to doom you? David Sedaris weighs in. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，如果命运让你和你的爱人没什么共同话题可聊，怎么办？你们注定没戏吗？这就足以让你们失败吗？戴维·塞达里斯对此发表看法。稍后为您播出，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
[MUSIC - "IT'S NOT UNUSUAL" BY WILLIE BOBO]
[音乐 - 威利·博博的《这不是不同寻常》]
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, for Valentine's Day, Star-crossed Love. And we've arrived at Act Two of our program.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种各样关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，情人节主题：苦命鸳鸯。我们现在进行到节目的第二幕。
Act Two, The Diary of Mrs. Sam Horrigan. Of course, there is no doomed love that ever seems quite as doomed as the doomed love that happens when you're in high school, Catalina Puente put together an account of doomed love in high school. She is a Radio Rookie at WNYC Radio in New York City. It's a program that trains teenagers how to make radio stories about their lives. A warning to listeners that although Catalina is a teenager, not everything in here might be appropriate for younger kids.
第二幕，萨姆·霍里根夫人的日记。当然，没有任何一种注定失败的爱情看起来像高中时的那种失败爱情一样注定。卡塔琳娜·普恩特整理了一份高中注定失败爱情的记叙。她是纽约市WNYC广播电台的一名“广播新秀”。这是一个培训青少年如何制作关于他们生活的广播故事的节目。警告听众，虽然卡塔琳娜是青少年，但这里面的内容可能不完全适合年幼的孩子。
I've loved Sam Horrigan since I was 13. I'm 16 now. He's an actor. You probably don't know him. He pops up in sitcoms once in a while. He always plays some type of bully.
我从13岁起就爱上了萨姆·霍里根。我现在16岁。他是个演员。你们可能不知道他。他偶尔会出现在情景喜剧里。他总是扮演某种恶霸角色。
Hey, Betty Crockers.
嘿，贝蒂·克罗克。
But he's my favorite actor. He was in this movie, Brink. I watched it over and over and over. I could spend up to a whole day thinking about him, but normally it's about four hours or so. Every time I go to the internet, I look up things about him and go onto websites to see what girls have to say about Sam.
但他是我最喜欢的演员。他演过一部电影叫《冲上云霄》。我看了又看，反反复复看了好多遍。我花上一整天想他也是常有的事，但通常也就四小时左右。每次上网，我都会搜索关于他的信息，去网站看看其他女孩对萨姆有什么评价。
I'm writing back to a few stupid girls that write about Sam. I wrote to this girl, and she wrote, "When I was 14, I got really drunk at Sam Horrigan's apartment and made out with him. Whoa."
我正在回击几个在网上谈论萨姆的蠢女孩。我给这个女孩写信，她写道：“14岁那年，我在萨姆·霍里根的公寓喝醉了，还和他亲吻了。哇。”
And then I wrote, "That is the most stupidest lie I have heard since the lie about, the world's going to end. And if it's true, I hope your tongue boils and burns into ashes. I am Sam's numero uno fan, OK? Now if I have to go all the way where you live to cut your head off for making such a big lie like that, I would."
然后我写道：“这是我听过的继‘世界末日即将来临’之后最愚蠢的谎言。如果这是真的，我希望你的舌头烂掉并烧成灰烬。我是萨姆的头号粉丝，懂吗？如果我必须不远万里去你住的地方，因为你撒了这么大的谎而砍掉你的头，我也做得出来。”
Then some other girl wrote after me. And she wrote, "Dude, chill. No need to threaten anybody. Sam is cool but no need to get all freaky."
然后另一个女孩回复了我。她写道：“伙计，冷静点。没必要威胁任何人。萨姆很酷，但没必要表现得那么变态。”
My schools are always crowded and loud. When I go up and down the stairs, I always bump into someone I know and say hi and bye. When I arrived at my high school as a freshman, a year and a half ago, I had no idea what was waiting for me there. I was going down the stairs when someone was coming up, and I got such a surprise because that person looked just like Sam. The eyebrows, white skin, black hair, same nose, eyes, lips, and the same strong jaw. That was what scared me the most. I went, "Oh, my God." But it wasn't Sam. It was just a regular student. It wasn't even a boy.
我的学校总是拥挤而嘈杂。走楼梯时，我总会撞到认识的人，打招呼再见。一年半前我刚上高一时，根本不知道那里在等着我什么。我下楼时有人上楼，我大吃一惊，因为那个人看起来就像萨姆。眉毛、白皙的皮肤、黑头发，同样的鼻子、眼睛、嘴唇，还有同样的坚毅下巴。这才是最让我害怕的地方。我心想：“天哪。”但那不是萨姆。那只是一个普通的学生。甚至不是个男生。
At the beginning, it just started with the feeling of how shocked I was that she looked like Sam. I guess I was too shocked to think I liked her. Before I knew her name, I'd think about her at home, calling her the Sam Girl. Later on, I found out her real name, but I'm only going to use the nickname that I gave her, which is K-licious, like the gum, Bubblicious. Now I have the letter K on my right thigh. I made it by rubbing my skin off with a toothpick. My older sister Maria thought what I did was crazy. My sister's 23, like Sam. The three most important people in my life are my sister, Sam, and God. My sister was the main witness to my obsession.
起初，仅仅是惊讶于她长得像萨姆的那种感觉。我猜我当时太震惊了，都没想过自己喜欢她。在她还不知道名字之前，我会在家想她，叫她“萨姆女孩”。后来，我打听到了她的真名，但我只打算用我给她的昵称，叫她“K-licious”，就像那种泡泡糖Bubblicious一样。现在我右大腿上有个字母K。这是我用牙签磨掉皮肤弄出来的。我姐姐玛丽亚觉得我疯了。我姐姐23岁，和萨姆一样大。我生命中最重要的三个人是我姐姐、萨姆和上帝。我姐姐是我痴迷的主要见证人。
It's plain to me how I used to be obsessed with this girl.
我很清楚自己曾经是多么痴迷这个女孩。
Oh, my God. Everything would remind you of her. Even if it had nothing to do with her, you would find something, and then say, "Oh, look. She wears this color. Or look, she was wearing these boots." It's ridiculous, ha ha, your friend gave you a gum. She gave you a gum that belonged to her, and you still have it. You have it there. And, "Oh, my God. What's that smell? What was that smell? That was her perfume. I know it. I know. I'm going to buy it. I'm going to buy it."
天哪。每一件事都会让你想起她。即使这件事跟她毫无关系，你也会找出联系，然后说：“哦，看。她穿这个颜色的衣服。或者看，她穿着那双靴子。”这太荒谬了，哈哈，朋友给了你一颗口香糖。她给了你一颗她吃过的口香糖，你还留着它。你把它放在那儿。然后，“天哪。那是什么味道？那是什么味道？那是她的香水味。我知道。我知道。我要买它。我要买它。”
She was the first girl I had different feelings for. Like, strong love feelings. When I heard any love song, especially "My Immortal" by Evanescence, I'd think about her. That song makes me so sad. It reminds me of the things we could have done if we were together.
她是第一个让我有不同感觉的女孩。那种强烈的爱。当我听到任何情歌时，尤其是伊凡塞斯的《我的不朽》，我就会想到她。那首歌让我好难过。它提醒我如果我们在一起可以做些什么。
[MUSIC - "MY IMMORTAL" BY EVANESCENCE]
[音乐 - 伊凡塞斯的《我的不朽》]
I'd just imagine the lights off, us in the bed, nose to nose, fingertips to fingertips, not saying a word except some "I love you's," playing with each other's hair, breathing each other's body scent. We're both happy.
我会想象灯关着，我们在床上，鼻子对着鼻子，指尖对着指尖，什么都不说，除了说几句“我爱你”，玩弄彼此的头发，呼吸着对方的体香。我们都很幸福。
[MUSIC - "MY IMMORTAL" BY EVANESCENCE]
[音乐 - 伊凡塞斯的《我的不朽》]
I wanted to marry the darn girl. I wanted to live with her. I wanted to spend the rest of my sorry life with her. I wanted to die with her. I wanted to be in heaven with her. Until K-licious, the only crushes I had for women were women on TV. I came out to my parents over her. My mom said she didn't care, that she still loved me. I only told my dad when I was asking my family about my obsession. I was scared that'd he'd see me differently, be disgusted or end the conversation. The day after I told him, we talked about it again.
我想娶那个该死的女孩。我想和她住在一起。我想和她共度余生。我想和她一起死。我想和她在天堂里在一起。直到遇到K-licious，我唯一喜欢的女性都是电视里的人。因为她，我向父母出柜了。我妈说她不在乎，她依然爱我。我只有在问家人关于我痴迷的事情时才告诉我爸。我害怕他会用不同的眼光看我，觉得恶心或结束谈话。告诉他后的第二天，我们又谈了谈。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
Something that I told you, that was important. What was that?
我告诉过你的一件事，那很重要。那是什么？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语发言]
Yes. That you used to like boys and girls.
是的。你以前喜欢男生和女生。
Yeah, and now.
是啊，现在也是。
And now, too. And you asked me how I felt about it. And I said that it happens to a lot of people.
现在也是。你问我怎么看。我说这种情况很多人都会发生。
And how do you feel, that I told you that? Do you feel different than last night?
那么你觉得怎么样，因为我告诉了你这些？你感觉和昨晚不同吗？
I feel good, happy because you have trust in me, to tell your dad everything. And I am happy with you.
我感觉很好，很高兴你能信任我，把一切都告诉你爸爸。我对你很满意。
It's easier to show your feelings to a boy, because that's how society is, for a guy and a girl to be together. I mean, a guy can't freak out when a girl tells you she likes you. I heard a rumor that some girl found out that I liked her and was going to curse me out in front of the whole school. I assumed K-licious saw the desk that I wrote her name on. I wrote that she was hot, and I thought she figured out about me crushing on her. I was scared and talked to a school counselor, who arranged a meeting with the two of us. I was so terrified, I thought I was going to pee in my pants.
向男生展示你的感受更容易，因为社会就是这样，认为男生和女生应该在一起。我的意思是，一个男生在女生说喜欢他时总不能崩溃吧。我听到传言说有个女孩发现我喜欢她，还打算在全校面前诅咒我。我以为K-licious看到了我写她名字的课桌。我写过她很辣，我以为她发现我迷恋她了。我很害怕，找了学校顾问，她安排了我们俩会面。我当时吓坏了，以为自己会吓尿裤子。
She came in, and I asked her if she heard anything bad about me. She looked clueless, and also beautiful. After a few seconds, she said, "No, but if I did, I wouldn't remember. I don't believe in 'he-said, she-said' rumors." Then I said, "Good, but if you hear anything bad about me, it's not true."
她进来了，我问她是否听说过关于我的坏话。她看起来一脸茫然，而且很美。过几秒钟，她说：“没有，但就算听说了，我也不会记得。我不相信那些流言蜚语。”然后我说：“很好，但如果你听到任何关于我的坏话，那都不是真的。”
When I talked to her, my heart beat fast, like, boom-boom, boom-boom, boom-boom. The obsession was like a second person. It felt like I was responsible for two people, my regular self and my obsessive self. In my house, I was unhappy most of the time. The depression was a new feeling. I was sad for myself that I felt this way over a girl who didn't even notice me. I would pray to God almost every night, telling him to send me a sign, that if I wasn't going to get with her, to make me stop liking her, but if I was, to let me keep going. My sister was getting annoyed.
当我和她说话时，我的心跳得很快，扑通、扑通、扑通。这种痴迷就像是第二个人。感觉我得负责两个人，我正常的自己和痴迷的自己。在家里，我大部分时间都不开心。抑郁是一种新的感觉。我为自己感到难过，因为我为了一个甚至没注意到我的女孩而有这种感觉。我几乎每天晚上都会向上帝祈祷，让他给我一个信号，如果我注定不能和她在一起，就让我别再喜欢她，但如果我能，就让我继续。我姐姐开始心烦了。
After I figured out that y'all were never going to get together, and this was going nowhere, I just wanted you to shut up about her, and to move on and leave her alone, because you guys were never going to be together.
在我发现你们永远不可能在一起，这注定没结果之后，我只是想让你闭嘴，别再提她，继续生活，别再纠缠她了，因为你们永远不可能在一起。
I started losing concentration in school, even though K-licious and I had no classes together. My report cards were disgusting. The feelings were so strong, they started to hurt. I used to cry in the bathroom because it was the only door with a lock.
我开始在学校注意力不集中，尽管我和K-licious没有任何课在一起。我的成绩单糟透了。那种感觉太强烈，以至于开始让我痛苦。我以前常在浴室里哭，因为那是唯一带锁的门。
I remember those mean days.
我记得那些糟糕的日子。
I wrote poems and haikus to clear out my mind.
我写诗和俳句来清空我的思绪。
I feel like I'm trapped. Trapped as the walls surround me. I want to get out.
我感觉自己被困住了。被困在墙壁中。我想出去。
Maria told me, "Don't tell me anything if you don't got her number or have not done anything with her." So what I used to do was, while I was in school, I used to think of a good lie to tell my sister, so that she could be interested in my talking about K-licious, because I had no one else to express myself to.
玛丽亚告诉我：“如果你没要到她的号码或者没跟她做过什么，就别告诉我任何事。”所以我常做的是，在学校时想出一个好谎话告诉我姐姐，好让她对我谈论K-licious感兴趣，因为我没处倾诉。
Almost every day, I would come home with a story. I felt scared to tell Maria about the lies, because she might lose trust in me. I decided to confess.
几乎每天，我回家都会编一个故事。我很害怕告诉玛丽亚那些谎话，因为她可能会失去对我的信任。我决定坦白。
Do you remember when I used to come from school and I used to tell you stuff, like what happened to me today?
你记得我从学校回来常告诉你事情，比如今天发生了什么吗？
Yeah.
记得。
Can you tell me one of the stories that you remember?
你能告诉我一个你记得的故事吗？
"Oh, today, guess what happened to me? I don't have my ID."
“哦，今天，猜猜我发生了什么？我没带身份证。”
I told Maria that K-licious stole my high school ID.
我告诉玛丽亚K-licious偷了我的高中身份证。
"And she said, oh, if you want it back, you'd better come to school, because you never come to school, so I can't wait to go back tomorrow. She's going to give me back my ID. Oh, my God, she's holding it. She put it in her back butt pocket. Oh, my God. When she gives it back to me, it's going to be from her pocket. Oh, my God."
“然后她说，哦，如果你想要回它，最好来学校，因为你从不来学校，所以我等不及明天回学校了。她会把身份证还给我的。天哪，她拿着它。她把它放进了屁股后面的口袋里。天哪。当她还给我时，它肯定带着她的口袋味。天哪。”
We're the stupidest sisters in the world.
我们是世界上最蠢的姐妹。
Are you in a good mood?
你心情好吗？
Why?
为什么？
I just want to know.
我就是想知道。
I'm always in a good mood.
我心情一直都很好。
I need to tell you something.
我需要告诉你一件事。
What you did?
你做了什么？
Something I need to confess to you.
我需要向你坦白。
You have another story.
你又有故事了。
No. Like half of them that I said--
不是。我说的那些故事有一半——
--were fake.
——都是假的。
How you came up with that?
你怎么想出来的？
I don't know.
我不知道。
Yeah.
是啊。
Why?
为什么？
Because you started saying, "I don't want to hear if it's nothing good." So that's why. I had nobody else to express myself to. So I used to lie, if I could talk to you.
因为你开始说，“如果是坏消息，我不想听。”所以才这样。我没处表达自己。所以我就撒谎，好让你能跟我聊聊。
You're an idiot. Oh, that's sick, girl.
你真是个白痴。哦，这太病态了，姑娘。
I know.
我知道。
Why would you do something like that? I'm not mad, but I'm just saying, that's so weird. Why you did that? You didn't have to.
你为什么要那样做？我不生气，但我只是说，这太奇怪了。你为什么要那样做？你没必要的。
I was surprised Maria didn't think it was such a big deal. I think why she didn't get mad with my confession was because she probably thought it was more stupid.
我很惊讶玛丽亚觉得那没什么大不了。我想她没对我坦白发火，是因为她可能觉得这更蠢。
Every time we had a school break, I'd think about how to slow down my obsession. Winter break was so depressing because I didn't see her, but then I started thinking about her less. But when I got back to school, it all fell on top of me again. Finally, the summer came, and there was a rumor that she might move, so I might never see her again. I decided to end the obsession.
每次学校放假，我都会思考如何减弱我的痴迷。寒假太抑郁了，因为见不到她，但后来我开始少想她了。但当我回到学校，一切又涌上心头。最后，暑假到了，有传言说她可能要搬走，所以我可能再也见不到她了。我决定结束这种痴迷。
I felt like an old lady whose husband just died after 50 years together. I tried not thinking about her, and I punished myself a little by not giving myself pleasure, like listening to songs and reading things that would remind me of her. Sam helped me a lot, too. I would watch Sam all the time. I kept watching the episode of the sitcom, Still Standing , that Sam starred in.
我感觉自己像个丈夫去世50年的老太太。我试着不去想她，我也惩罚自己，不让自己获得快乐，比如听那些会让我想起她的歌和读关于她的东西。萨姆也帮了我很多。我总是看萨姆。我一直看萨姆主演的情景喜剧《依然站立》。
"Because he's a butler, dude. He does anything we tell him to. He's our designated driver, he goes on burger runs, he does our homework."
“因为他是个管家，伙计。我们让他做什么他就做什么。他是我们的指定司机，去买汉堡，做家庭作业。”
Babysits my son.
帮我看孩子。
Wow, buddy.
哇，伙计。
Even though K-licious looks like him, it was a whole different kind of love than what I had for Sam. Plus, it started with her because I know I'm not going to get with Sam. I miss K-licious, but by the end of the summer, my obsession was leaving.
尽管K-licious长得像他，但那和对萨姆的爱完全不同。而且，这始于她，因为我知道我不可能和萨姆在一起。我想念K-licious，但到了夏天结束时，我的痴迷已经消失了。
On the bus on the first day back, I was nervous that if she was there, I might fall in love with her again. When I got to school, I saw her, but I didn't react like I thought I would. I have classes with her now, unlike before when I just wished I did.
返校第一天的车上，我很紧张，怕如果她也在，我可能会再次爱上她。到学校后，我看到了她，但我并没有像我想象的那样做出反应。我现在和她有课，不像以前那样只是希望有。
I'd get uptight for the first 10 minutes, but then I'd just relax and forget that she's in the class. If that was me last year, I don't know what I would do. I know I wouldn't be relaxed.
前10分钟我会有点紧绷，但随后我就会放松，忘了她在课堂上。如果是去年的我，我不知道我会怎么样。我知道我肯定没法放松。
Maria asked me if I was completely over K-licious. I stood speechless for a while. I wanted to say that the obsession was gone, but decided to answer as honest as I could, because I didn't want Maria to doubt what I was saying. I have to admit that I am 99% over her. But there's 1% that I still, I don't know.
玛丽亚问我是不是完全放下了K-licious。我沉默了很久。我想说痴迷已经消失了，但我决定尽可能诚实地回答，因为我不想玛丽亚怀疑我说的话。我必须承认，我已经有99%放下她了。但还有1%我仍然，我不知道。
It's scary, because I don't want to think about her, but sometimes I just do. I still like K-licious, but not so, so in love. I have a piece of love in my heart, that my heart won't let me erase. Until I have a real relationship, maybe I'm not going to be completely over her.
这很可怕，因为我不想想起她，但有时我就是会想起。我仍然喜欢K-licious，但没有那么那么相爱了。我心里有一小块爱，我的心不让我抹去它。直到我有一段真正的感情，也许我才不会完全放下她。
For This American Life , this is Catalina Puente, aka Mrs. Sam Horrigan.
为《美国生活》，这是卡塔琳娜·普恩特，又名萨姆·霍里根夫人。
[MUSIC - "MY IMMORTAL" BY EVANESCENCE]
[音乐 - 伊凡塞斯的《我的不朽》]
Catalina Puente in New York with WNYC's Radio Rookies, whose story was produced by Serena Patel with assistance from Miguel Macias, Wayne Schulmister, and Karen Michel. Other stories by Radio Rookies at www.radiorookies.org. Catalina's story was supported by Con Edison, the Fred L. Emerson Foundation, the National Endowment for the Arts, Open Society Institute's Youth Initiatives program, the Helena Rubinstein Foundation, the Surdna Foundation, Rockefeller Philanthropy Advisors, the New York Times Company Foundation, and Time Warner.
卡塔琳娜·普恩特在纽约参加WNYC的“广播新秀”节目，该故事由塞雷娜·帕特尔制作，并得到米格尔·马西亚斯、韦恩·舒尔米斯特和凯伦·米歇尔的协助。更多“广播新秀”故事请访问 www.radiorookies.org。卡塔琳娜的故事得到了爱迪生联合公司、弗雷德·L·爱默生基金会、国家艺术基金会、开放社会研究所青年倡议项目、海伦娜·鲁宾斯坦基金会、瑟德纳基金会、洛克菲勒慈善咨询公司、《纽约时报》公司基金会和时代华纳的支持。
Act Three. So a Squirrel and a Chipmunk Walk Into a Bar. We end our program today with this fable of doomed love from David Sedaris.
第三幕，花栗鼠和松鼠走进一家酒吧。我们以戴维·塞达里斯的这个注定失败的爱情寓言结束今天的节目。
The squirrel and the chipmunk had been dating for two weeks when they ran out of things to talk about. Acorns, parasites, the inevitable approach of autumn, these subjects had been covered within their first hour. And so, breathlessly, their faces had flushed. Twice they had held long conversations about dogs, each declaring their across-the-board hatred of them, and speculating on what life might be like were someone to put a bowl of food in front of them two times a day.
松鼠和花栗鼠约会两周后，就没话可说了。橡子、寄生虫、秋天不可避免的临近，这些话题在他们第一个小时里就聊完了。于是，他们面红耳赤，气喘吁吁。他们曾两次长谈关于狗的话题，每人都宣称对狗完全讨厌，并猜测如果有人每天给它们放两碗食物，生活会是什么样子。
"They're spoiled rotten, is what it comes down to," the chipmunk had said.
“它们被宠坏了，归根结底就是这样，”花栗鼠曾说。
And the squirrel had placed his paw over hers, saying, "That's it, exactly. Finally, someone who really gets it."
松鼠把爪子放在她的爪子上，说：“就是这样，一点没错。终于有人真正理解了。”
Friends had warned them that their romance could not possibly work out. And such moments convinced them that these naysayers were not just wrong, but jealous. "They'll never have what we do," the squirrel would say. And then the two of them would sit quietly, hoping for a flash flood or a rifle report, something, anything that might generate a conversation.
朋友们警告他们这段恋情不可能成功。而那一刻让他们确信这些反对者不仅错了，而且是嫉妒。“他们永远不会拥有我们这样的一切，”松鼠会说。然后两人会静静地坐着，希望能有山洪暴发或枪声，什么都行，任何能引发对话的事情。
They were out one night at a little bar run by a couple of owls when, following a long silence, the squirrel slapped his palm against the table top. "You know what I like?" he said. "I like jazz."
一天晚上他们在一对猫头鹰经营的小酒吧里，经过长时间的沉默，松鼠猛地拍了一下桌子。“你知道我喜欢什么吗？”他说。“我喜欢爵士乐。”
"I didn't know that," the chipmunk said. "My goodness. Jazz." She had no idea what jazz was, but worried that asking would make her sound stupid and unworthy of his affections. "What kind, exactly?" she asked, hoping his answer might narrow things down a bit.
“我不知道，”花栗鼠说。“天哪。爵士乐。”她根本不知道什么是爵士乐，但担心问出来会显得自己很蠢，配不上他的深情。“到底是什么样的？”她问，希望他的回答能缩小一下范围。
"Well, all kinds really," he told her, "especially the earlier stuff."
“嗯，各种各样的都有，真的，”他告诉她，“尤其是早期的东西。”
"Me too," she said. And when he asked her why, she told him that the later stuff was just a little too late for her tastes, almost like it was overripe or something, you know what I mean? And for the third time since she had known him, the squirrel reached across the table and took her paw.
“我也是，”她说。当他问为什么时，她告诉他后期的东西对她的口味来说太晚了，就像是熟过头了一样，你知道我的意思吗？这是她认识他以来第三次，松鼠伸过手抓住了她的爪子。
On returning home that evening, the chipmunk woke her older sister, with whom she shared a room. "Listen," she whispered. "I need you to explain something. What's jazz?"
那天晚上回到家，花栗鼠叫醒了她同住的姐姐。“听着，”她低声说。“我需要你解释一下。什么是爵士乐？”
"Why are you asking me?" the sister said.
“你为什么问我？”姐姐说。
"So you don't know either?" the chipmunk asked.
“所以你也不知道？”花栗鼠问。
"I didn't say I didn't know," the sister said. "I asked you why you're asking. Does this have anything to do with that squirrel?"
“我没说我不知道，”姐姐说。“我问你为什么要问。这跟那只松鼠有关系吗？”
"Maybe," the chipmunk said.
“也许吧，”花栗鼠说。
"Well, I'm telling," the sister announced. "First thing tomorrow morning, because this has gone on long enough." She punched at her pillow of moss, then repositioned it beneath their head. "I warned you weeks ago that this wouldn't work out. And now you've got the whole house in an uproar, waltzing home in the middle of the night, waking me up with your dirty little secrets. Jazz indeed. You just wait until Mother hears about this."
“好啊，我去告状，”姐姐宣布。“明天一早，因为这事儿够久了。”她捶了捶苔藓枕头，重新在她们的头下放好。“几周前我就警告过你，这不会有好结果的。现在你把家里闹得鸡犬不宁，大半夜回家，用你那些肮脏的小秘密吵醒我。爵士乐，哼。你等着听妈怎么说吧。”
The chipmunk lay awake that night, imagining the unpleasantness that was bound to take place the following morning. What if jazz was squirrel slang for something terrible, like anal intercourse? "Oh, I like it too," she'd said, and so eagerly. Then again, it could just be mildly terrible, something along the lines of Communism or fortune-telling, subjects that were talked about but hardly ever practiced. Just as she thought she'd calmed herself down, a new possibility would enter her mind, each one more terrible than the last.
花栗鼠那天晚上躺着睡不着，想象着第二天早上不可避免要发生的不愉快。如果“爵士乐”是松鼠关于某种可怕事情的俚语，比如肛交呢？“哦，我也喜欢，”她刚才说得那么热切。再说，它也可能只是稍微可怕一点，类似于共产主义或算命，这些话题常被讨论但几乎从不实践。就在她以为自己平静下来时，一个新的可能性涌上心头，每一个都比上一个更可怕。
Jazz was a maggot-infested flesh of a dead body. The ochre crust on an infected eye. Another word for ritual suicide. And she had claimed to like it.
爵士乐是死尸身上长满蛆虫的肉。感染眼睛上的赭色结痂。或者是仪式性自杀的另一个词。而她竟然说她喜欢。
Years later, when she could put it all in perspective, she'd realized that she'd never really trusted the squirrel. How else to explain all those terrible possibilities? Had he been another chipmunk, even a tough one, she'd have assumed that jazz was something familiar, a kind of root, say, or maybe a hairstyle. Of course, her sister hadn't helped any. None of her family had.
多年后，当她能从全局看问题时，她意识到她从未真正信任过那只松鼠。否则怎么解释所有那些可怕的可能性？如果他是另一只花栗鼠，哪怕是强壮的那种，她也会认为爵士乐是某种熟悉的东西，比如一种根茎，或者是某种发型。当然，她姐姐没帮上忙。她的家人都没帮上忙。
"It's not that I have anything against squirrels, per se," her mother had said. "It's just that this one-- well, I don't like him." When pressed for details, she'd mentioned his fingernails, which were a little too long for her tastes. "A sure sign of vanity," she warned. "And then there's this jazz business."
“并不是我本质上对松鼠有什么偏见，”她母亲曾说。“只是这一只——嗯，我不喜欢他。”当被追问细节时，她提到了他的指甲，那对她的口味来说太长了。“这是虚荣的铁证，”她警告道。“还有这该死的爵士乐。”
That was what did it. Following a sleepless night, the chipmunk's mother had forced her to break it off.
这就是原因。经过一个不眠之夜，花栗鼠的母亲强迫她结束了这段感情。
"Well, the squirrel had sighed. "I guess that's that."
“嗯，”松鼠叹了口气。“我想就这样吧。”
"I guess it is," the chipmunk said. He headed downriver a few days later, and she never saw him or spoke to him again.
“我想也是，”花栗鼠说。几天后他顺流而下，她再也没见过他，也没和他说过话。
"It's no great loss," her sister said. "No girl should be subjected to language like that, especially from the likes of him."
“没什么损失，”姐姐说。“任何女孩都不应该受到那种语言的折磨，尤其是像他那样的人。”
"Amen," her mother added.
“阿门，”母亲补充道。
Eventually, the chipmunk met someone else, and after she had safely married, her mother speculated that perhaps Jazz was a branch of medicine, something like chiropractic therapy that wasn't quite legitimate. Her sister said, no. It was more likely a jig. And then she pushed herself back from the table and kicked her chubby legs into the air.
最终，花栗鼠遇到了别人，在她安稳地结婚后，她母亲猜测也许爵士乐是医学的一个分支，类似于脊椎按摩疗法，不太正规。姐姐说，不是。更有可能是跳吉格舞。然后她把身子往后一仰，把圆滚滚的腿踢向空中。
"Oh, you," her mother said. "That's a can-can." And then she joined in and gave a few kicks of her own. This stuck in the squirrel's mind, for she never knew her mother could identify a dance step, or anything associated with fun.
“哦，你呀，”母亲说。“那是康康舞。”然后她也加入进来，自己踢了几下。这印在松鼠的脑海里，因为她从不知道她母亲能辨认出舞步，或是任何与乐趣相关的东西。
It was the way her own children would eventually think of her: dull, strict, chained to the past. She had boys, all of them healthy and only one prone to trouble. He had a habit of being in the wrong place at the wrong time, but his heart was good, and the chipmunk knew he would eventually straighten himself out. Her husband thought so too, and died knowing that he had been correct. A month or two after he'd passed on, she asked this son what Jazz was, and when he told her it was a kind of music, she knew immediately that he was telling the truth.
这就是她自己的孩子最终对她的看法：沉闷、严格、束缚于过去。她生了男孩，都很健康，只有一个容易惹麻烦。他习惯于在错误的时间出现在错误的地点，但他心地善良，花栗鼠知道他最终会变好的。她的丈夫也是这么认为的，死时就知道他是对的。他去世一两个月后，她问这个儿子什么是爵士乐，当他告诉她那是一种音乐时，她立刻知道他说的是实话。
"Is it bad music?" she asked.
“那是坏音乐吗？”她问。
"Well, if it's played badly," he said. "Otherwise, it's really quite pleasant."
“嗯，如果演奏得很烂的话，”他说。“否则，它实际上非常悦耳。”
"Did squirrels invent it?"
“是松鼠发明的吗？”
"God, no," he said. "Whoever gave you that idea?"
“天哪，不，”他说。“谁给你这种想法的？”
The chipmunk stroked her brown and white muzzle. "Nobody," she said. "I was just guessing."
花栗鼠抚摸着她棕白相间的口鼻部。“没谁，”她说。“我只是在瞎猜。”
When her muzzle grew more white than brown, the chipmunk forgot that she and the squirrel had had nothing to talk about. She forgot the definition of Jazz as well, and came to think of it as every beautiful thing she had ever failed to appreciate: the taste of warm rain, the smell of a baby, the din of a swollen river rushing past her tree and onward to infinity.
当她的口鼻部变得白多棕少时，花栗鼠忘记了她和那只松鼠曾没什么可聊的。她也忘记了爵士乐的定义，并把它看作是她一生中未能欣赏的所有美好事物：温暖雨水的味道、婴儿的气味、湍急河流掠过她树木奔向无限远方的喧嚣。
David Sedaris' most recent book is Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim. He's also the editor of an anthology of favorite short stories called Children Playing Before a Statue of Hercules .
戴维·塞达里斯最近的书是《穿灯芯绒和牛仔裤的家人》。他也是短篇小说选集《在赫拉克勒斯雕像前玩耍的孩子》的编辑。
Our program was produced today by Jane Feltes and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Sarah Koenig, Amy O'Leary, and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Sam Hallgren, Thea Chaloner, Seth Lind, and Tommy Andres. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
今天的节目由简·费尔特斯和我制作，参与者还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克、莎拉·柯尼格、艾米·奥利里和丽莎·波拉克。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。萨姆·哈尔格伦、西娅·查洛纳、塞思·林德和汤米·安德烈提供了制作帮助。杰西卡·霍珀提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, where you can sign up for our free, our absolutely free weekly podcast, or listen to all of our old shows by audio streaming, www.thisamericanlife.org. Or for the podcast, you can go to the iTunes store.
我们的网站，您可以在那里注册我们免费的、绝对免费的每周播客，或者通过音频流收听我们所有的老节目，www.thisamericanlife.org。对于播客，您可以访问iTunes商店。
This week on the website, there's information about our upcoming six-city national tour. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
本周网站上，有关于我们即将进行的六个城市全国巡演的信息。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program provided by Mr. Torey Malatia, who does not understand why we have so many women on our staff.
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生提供，他不明白为什么我们员工里有这么多女性。
Do they do the same work as men?
她们做的工作和男人一样吗？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories on This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回到《美国生活》节目中为您带来更多故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。